I think that this film is perfect for  imax I mean Peter Burke's style of  shooting his storytelling is big and  massive I think I max will sort of make  you really feel like you're in it which  will be a very intense experience that  is a genuine dinosaur tooth communica  there's no way in deepwater horizon to  understand the experience the people had  and understand the emotions they have  unless you can give the enormity of the  calamity the proper size in imax you're  probably gonna get that in spades like  what is that everything okay  you are going to feel the intensity that  we felt while shooting it and maybe get  a glimpse of what those survivors and  those that lost their lives felt as well  and I'm ex is probably the only place  you'll feel that  you